as we look to the future of games with
platforms like unreal engine 5 it's now
time to celebrate the best games of this
year to present game of the year please
welcome last year's winner of game of
the year and best game direction from
naughty dog neil druckmann
[Applause]
thanks jeff
man it feels awesome to be back here
together in person congratulations to
everyone who managed to release a game
this year perseverance dedication
and passion are inspiring and there's no
shortage of that in this room
now performing music from each of
tonight's game of the year nominees once
again the game awards orchestra
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
that was fantastic a fitting way to
honor the very best of the year let's
hear it one more time for the game
awards orchestra
[Applause]
and finally congratulations to all of
tonight's nominees
all pretty incredible games
and the 2021 game of the year is
it takes two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oscar and now
uh
actually in a way that the officers got
[ __ ] because the game awards is
getting way better so
i wanna i know there are 30 seconds i'm
going to be extremely fast so i want to
take my uh
let me see my my beautiful team for a
fantastic world obviously without that i
can't do anything and also i want to say
also i want to
give this award to my daughter miyo am i
soon to come daughter zoe it's so nice
to have children i'm surprised how much
you love them if you don't have children
go get them i mean it's the best thing
that can happen
thank you again i'm really i'm shaking
look at me man this is like a big big
moment for me and neil you're a big
inspiration thank you thank you
[Music]
congratulations
joseph ferris so amazing all right what
did you think of the winners tonight did
your favorite game win if not post your
thoughts with a youtube short and let us
know who got shorted tonight thank you
again for watching the game awards we
will see you next summer for summer game
fest
such a pleasure that we got to do this
in person thank you so much have a great
holiday season good night everybody
[Applause]